ههه
سيدي هيا ايوه ههه
صديقي كاتب في البدايه احق احدهم ااه كاتب
بالبدايه تبع البوست احدهم همس لي انا
الحقيقه كنت قاعد مع مجموعه اصدقاء في رجل
مكافئ اشتغل في السعوديه سنوات طويله قال
لي بتعرف استاذ من زمان كنا نسافر لنجي
نشتري بيت هلا هو بعد ما اشتغل البيت
نتيجه الضغط
انا قلت همسه لي احدهم حقيقه استوقفني
وحزنت عليه فهمني اما الناس
مقطوعه ترى فيها شيء ادبي يشبه القصه
القصيره جدا يعتبرون انك تتحدث عن نفسك
انا لم افلس
اصلا قبل في شرط قبل الافلاس معروف في
الحياه ان يكون الواحد غني جدا فالشرط
الاول انا لم اكن فيه يوما فبالتالي هذا
مفهوم الافلاس انا انا لم افلس اعيش حياتي
لم افلس اطلاقا ولم ابيع بيتي ولا استطيع
ان اغادر ولن اغادر ولا استطيع ان اغادر
طوعان انا رجل جسور جيلنا كله هو مرتبط
عميقا في هذه الارض هذا الوطن لنا لن
نتركه وسنضل فيه من مواجهه تحديات نتوتر
يمكن احيانا نختلف على بعض الاشياء نستطيع
لكن هو بالاخر نتحرك في الفضاء الذي فيه
ذكرياتنا وفي بيوم من الايام احلامنا وحتى
اللي في خيباتنا وانكسار هذه الجغرافيا
لها في روحنا انت بتمشي في دمشق على شارع
عمره 10,000 سنه 10,000 سنه سبقتك على هذا
الشارع خطوات كثير من الاحبه ومن الاجداد
ومن العظام ومن الموجوعين ومن البسطاء هذا
مكاني وهذا وطني وانا بقيت بهذا المفهوم
خارج الحديث اصبح اسلم متاخر عن مفهوم
الحرب والاصطفاف السياسي والمعارضه
والنظام وهذه الاسطوانه المشروخه التي لم
توصل الى المكان الذي كنا جميعا نشتهي
الان الحديث ان ندافع عن هذه الارض ان
تعود هذه الارض لانه سوريا ارض عظيمه ارد
عظيمه ولها علينا الكثير يعني هي ارض ارض
حضاره
ابجديه ارض